[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo
ante la situación de kobe 19 ahora
trabajamos desde casa obtener una línea
telefónica en méxico ahora requerirá que
usted proporcione hasta sus datos
biométricos como huellas dactilares o
las facciones de su rostro el senado
aprobó una ley que así lo dispone y el
mecanismo genera preocupación sobre la
privacidad y la seguridad de los
usuarios que hay detrás de esta
normativa y que dicen quienes se oponen
a ella empezamos el senado de méxico
aprobó reformar la ley federal de
telecomunicaciones y radiodifusión para
crear el polémico padrón nacional de
usuarios de telefonía móvil esta nueva
normativa impulsada por el grupo
parlamentario del partido gobernante
morena busca crear una gran base de
datos de todas y cada una de las
personas que tengan una línea telefónica
tanto en la modalidad pospago como
prepago los usuarios tendrán que
proporcionar varios datos personales que
van desde el nombre hasta la
nacionalidad pero lo que más generó
malestar entre los senadores opositores
y en la población en general es que los
usuarios
estarán obligados a registrar su
información biométrica como por ejemplo
las huellas dactilares facciones del
rostro o el iris según los promotores de
esta regulación el objetivo es frenar
los delitos como la extorsión el fraude
y el secuestro que se cometen mediante
el uso de teléfonos celulares ya que
según dicen gracias al padrón podrán
identificar a quienes están detrás de
cada línea telefónica según la cámara
nacional de la industria electrónica de
telecomunicaciones y tecnologías de la
información en la actualidad hay 126
millones de líneas móviles en el país y
de esa cifra el 85% usa la modalidad de
pago es decir tarjetas que en general se
pueden conseguir sin ningún tipo de
documentación en redes sociales son más
los que rechazan la medida que quienes
la defienden y de hecho la han
calificado como autoritaria bajo el
numeral no al padrón tanto ciudadanos
como organizaciones defensoras de
derechos humanos advierten sobre los
riesgos que representaría el hecho de
que los datos biométricos de una persona
fueran a parar a las manos equivocadas
la base de datos estará disponible para
que agencias gubernamentales la
consulten sin ninguna orden judicial
denuncian también que se afectara la
presunción de inocencia de un usuario
cuya línea haya sido robada y utilizada
para cometer delitos en france 24
consultamos a priscila ruiz coordinadora
legal del programa de derechos digitales
de la ong artículo 19 quien expresó sus
objeciones frente al tema que tampoco
este tipo de reforma está homologada o
está armonizada con lo que vi con lo que
dice la ley sobre protección de datos
personales que resulta elemental y
fundamental para saber de qué manera
este tipo de patrón va a recabar
nuestros datos que datos que autoridades
los van a utilizar cómo se va a proteger
este tipo de datos y esto justo lo que
hace es poner en riesgo la privacidad la
identidad e incluso la integridad física
y emocional de las de las propias
personas usar van más allá el impacto
que no se está evaluando ni tampoco se
está tomando en consideración este tipo
de regulación no es no
en mexico en 2008 nació el llamado
registro nacional de usuarios de
telecomunicaciones o simplemente
conocido como rain out fue una
iniciativa del entonces presidente
felipe calderón que también buscaba
combatir el secuestro y la extorsión el
renaut pretendía privar a los
delincuentes del anonimato obligando a
los dueños de líneas telefónicas a
registrarlas con sus respectivos números
de identificación sin embargo este
mecanismo se eliminó en 2011 luego de
que se conociera que la base de datos
fue filtrada y la información de los
usuarios se vendía en el mercado ilegal
de acuerdo con la ong mexicana red de
defensa para los derechos digitales en
lugar de reducir el crimen la extorsión
aumentó en un 48 por ciento el secuestro
en 18 % durante el tiempo de vigencia de
dicho registro la mayoría de los países
requieren que las líneas telefónicas
están registradas con los datos
personales del usuario o titular pero
algunos llegan a ser más invasivos que
otros de acuerdo con un estudio de la
compañía de investigación tecnológica
con pari tec que revisa y compara
productos tecnológicos al menos 17
países alrededor del mundo recopilan de
alguna forma
los biométricos para el registro de la
tarjeta sin entre ellos china venezuela
arabia saudita emiratos árabes y
tailandia países que el instituto
internacional para la democracia y la
asistencia electoral calificó como
regímenes autoritarios en su reporte de
2019 sobre el estado global de la
democracia
todos los medios de comunicación de
méxico abordaron la noticia en sus
páginas principales pero cada uno con un
enfoque distinto
'el universal' consulta en su titular
confiaría sus datos biométricos a una
compañía telefónica el periódico
excélsior dice cerrado avala entregar
sus datos biométricos al gobierno para
el uso del celular el portal de noticias
animal político titula senado avala
registro obligatorio de usuarios de
telefonía móvil pese a riesgos en
seguridad de privacidad mientras que la
edición mexicana de la revista forbes
titula con la postura de la compañía de
teléfonos estadounidense el quintil que
también opera en méxico y que dice que
hay mecanismos más efectivos y menos
complejos que un padrón para combatir la
extorsión
y despedimos con una campaña que se ha
hecho viral en todo el mundo y que tiene
como objetivo crear conciencia sobre la
crueldad que hay detrás de las pruebas
cosméticas en animales se trata de stage
road o salvemos el round un corto
animado de la organización him en sus
air international en el que un conejo
llamado round cuenta cómo es su día a
día en un laboratorio expuesto a una
serie de químicos que llegaron a afectar
su visión y audición la historia de
rauch quien agrega que toda su familia
ha muerto en estos proyectos ha
conmovido a usuarios en redes sociales
que además de promover el corto han
compartido una lista de empresas
cosméticas que aún hacen pruebas con
animales que han instado a sus
seguidores a dejar de consumir estos
productos
así despedimos esta edición de revista
digital recuerde que si quiere repetir
esta u otra emisión de nuestro programa
lo puede hacer a través de nuestra
página web www punto frente 4 punto com
[Música]